well congratulations on the nomination
thank you girl I just want to what is
amazing it's incredible so crazy can you
even believe it how does it feel no I
mean honestly just like the warmth the
love that this album has received is
just blowing my mind I mean I just make
it because it makes me feel good and
then anything outside of that is truly
really cool so performing in the Dali
tribute let's talk a little bit about
how Dali has impacted your career okay I
mean how has she not first of all she's
she's an earth angel she really is and
she's so cool she's so present she's
very what I like about her is that she's
a keen attention to detail and that's
obviously why she's had such a long
amazing career is because she really
cares about those things she can put her
stamp on you know put her stamp on
things without apologies and she's been
great to work with so professional and
so nice very welcoming to the newbies
really in the grand scheme so yeah it's
a whole amazing sort of group of you
singing with her it's like you know
you're in this amazing lineup of people
who are paying respects to her and they
must be really special to stand next to
your peers with Dali at the center of it
I'm sure all of us are inspired by her
in many different ways but she paved the
way for a lot of us especially in
country music you know we wouldn't
really be able to do what we do without
her she's the first who had all of it
together the sex appeal the brains the
humor the songwriting and I don't the
outfits obviously the hair so I can't
let you go without asking a little
fashion tell me a secret about this
dress Oh a secret
well it's Valentino couture it's really
actually so comfortable and I feel like
that is like rarity like sometimes
you're like I can't breathe and it's
fine my ribs are cracking in half
and I guess maybe a little secret is
that I kind of reminded me of a fan
which is kind of like a nod to the cover
of my album so that's a one reason why I
really liked it okay see good luck
tonight I'll move the year we really
hope you win
[Music]